I'ma what?
Yeah, now you're quiet. You're quiet, right? This is what we're talking about this what we talked about, right?
what am I how about tell me tell me what I am tell me tell me what I am a
Lot of people thought this year was a throwaway year but perhaps this is the year that gives us 20/20 vision
There's a huge movement underway
Currently we all know this we all know why it started breaking news in the killing of George Floyd his cries
I can't breathe sparking protests across the country over the last nine days at a time when police misconduct is in the spotlight
There's a social contract that we all have that if you steal or if I steal the person who is the authority comes in and
They fix the situation
But the person who fixes the situation is killing us
Yesterday we sat down to try and figure out what we're going to say and how we're going to say it
What actions did we want to take both as people and as a company in all my time in quarter?
And I've had an incredible time here. We've never discussed race and our experience with it in America
Now I was hesitant to have this conversation for many reasons. It's an incredible weight to carry
I wear this skin
Every day the pain of my ancestors is literally embedded in my DNA
So I don't want to misrepresent my community worse than the wrong message
Some might say by having this discussion you bring the monster back to life and feed into the divide that we sometimes pretend
Doesn't actually exist but the opposite is true by having this discussion
We're able to address the fact that there is a bubble and now it's time to pop that bubble
But okay, you might ask. How does any of this help? How do I help should I even help right now? There's many mixed signals
donations marching staying silent being vocal posting on Instagram
Rioting everyone is taking a different approach and many people still don't know what to do to support the movement nor do they understand it?
Enough to make a difference. So I want to give you the most recent example of lingering systemic oppression that is still present today
Literally yesterday I'm writing my one-wheel
I'm coming up on the right hand of someone and I say, excuse me on your right I passed by the man
He was a little startled, but then I heard him screaming. So I take off my headphones. I look back and he's yelling you stupid
Don't ever pass me
Literally right there is what we're talking about. This is what we talk about, right?
What am I how about tell me tell me what I am tell me tell me what I am
Exactly
This is the problem people
This right here this man feels superior enough to talk down on me as if I am nothing as he's yelling at me
I'm looking at him and I just I feel bad for him
I'm pretty sure this is something that was tots and regardless of where he's at today
It just proves that this hatred is so ingrained in his heart. It's still
bubbles
So back to the conversation we sat down and tried to figure out what actionable steps we could take and this
Conversation lasted for five hours and it wasn't until the end of that that we realized
We had actually just done the most valuable thing we could do. We had popped the bubble
We had addressed the elephant in the room prior to the horrific killings of Brianna Taylor Ahmad Aubrey and George Floyd
I would never have had this type of discussion with the guys
I would have been in my own bubble with my black friends
discussing our pain like the fact that I would just discuss with my friends then come in and just as business as normal is
A problem within itself, you know, we have to be able to be open and acknowledge that there is a problem
That's that's the that's the beauty in in this new
Revolution that we're living in that were discussing things that we'd never
That we pretty much ignore is the elephant in the room
We are fully addressing. They were standing right in front of it and being like yo, this isn't right
It's a great feeling but you know, it doesn't just it is a stop after that
It's like we we are making a change for the future, you know for your kids
You know for your kids for everyone's kids honestly like in that right?
There is just amazing like this moment right here me and you chillin and talking about something we never II
I've never had a discussion like this
Never through conversations bad ideas get exposed to sunlight and they wither away so here at corridor
We would like to encourage you to go out and have a hard conversation
And if your views cannot withstand being challenged then perhaps those views aren't worth having in the first place
I've been dying for this ice cream all day. Oh, you can't go wrong with cookies and cream and a cone on top
It's like ice cream. Oh, yeah, okay, okay
So this video is part of an ongoing conversation
To help educate the world on steps that we can take to help end
systemic racism and the vilification of black people
Let us know in the comments below the conversations you plan on happening or if you've already had these ongoing conversations
because if we keep the conversation going
This doesn't just become a fad that fades. It becomes part of our culture in the description
You'll find a compilation of organizations that you can donate to if you choose to add to this
Please DM my friend Royce
He'll be more than happy to add any type of information that can help this movement continue going
Thank you so much for watching this video and let's change the world together